before Donald Trump's big virus address
last night he had some reporters into a
meeting about about contingency planning
and CNN's Jim Acosta asked a really
specific question to Donald Trump and a
good question to Donald Trump and it was
there are people concerned you aren't
taking this seriously enough there are
people noticing that what you say and
what health experts say are two very
very different things what do you say to
those people Donald Trump's answer was
merely that CNN that's fake news no
answer the President of the United
States mishandling or not handling a
crisis about which he is clueless jiya
cNN's Jim Acosta accurately points out
health experts are saying very different
things than you and they are health
experts and this is Donald Trump's
reaction that you're not taking this
seriously enough and that some of your
statements don't match what your health
experts are saying in many other
developed Western democracies that
respect the press and hold elected
officials accountable a president would
be run out of office for simultaneously
mismanaging a crisis while attacking
journalists who inquire about it it has
become very popular for trumpets to
attack CNN and that's dangerous enough
but what I need you to understand is
that no one is holding the president
accountable he shut down the pandemic
response team in 2018
he cut funding to the CDC we're gonna
dig into this later he denied that this
was anything at all until he had no
choice but to do an emergency
presidential address to the nation from
the White House last night and now when
a journalist asks a simple sober real
important question a a substantive
question Trump refuses to answer and
cause the employer of the journalists
fake news now as far as the suspension
of travel for foreigners coming here
from coming to the United States from
Europe the problem is here now the virus
is spreading here it's undetected
because we aren't testing and our system
doesn't work and Trump is being asked
about his mismanagement
and he is allowed to say your fake news
and simply move on the everything else
aside the lack of testing should be
career-ending for Donald Trump it should
be a presidency ending mistake and we'll
talk about that later the stock market
again crashing today once again the
stock market crashed so much so quickly
that these emergency circuit breaker
measures were triggered which stopped
trading altogether I was actually
wondering last night as the stock market
futures started to implode as Trump was
speaking what would have happened if
Trump said I'm resigning and someone
actually qualified was put in place
obviously not pence I thought that
wouldn't be a qualified person I was
just thinking would that turn anything
around about what's going on I don't
know at this point in time
check out the excellent YouTube channel
we're partnering up with called up flip
you can get there at david pakman.com
slash up flip the link is right
underneath this video make sure you
subscribe while you are there up flip is
a youtube channel that looks at
entrepreneurship in a very interesting
way their content looks at small
businesses what makes them successful
each video you get to meet a new
entrepreneur get a behind-the-scenes
look at their daily grind learn their
philosophy learn their business as a
business owner myself as someone with an
MBA I love watching the content there's
a ton of really useful insight to come
away with from every episode I love
hearing what the entrepreneurs share you
get practical advice they talk about
outside the box strategies and even if
you don't own a small business yourself
I think you'd be fascinated by the
content on up flip perfect for people
who like shows like Shark Tank and that
sort of thing get to the up flip YouTube
channel by going to david pakman.com
slash up flip the link is underneath the
video there friends of the david pakman
show definitely make sure to subscribe
to their channel click that Bell icon on
their page so you'll be notified
whenever they upload a new video